[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
In meinem heutigen Video geht es darum,
wie man Lebensmittel haltbar machen kann.
Meine Mama hat mir beigebracht,
immer einen gesunden Vorrat an Lebensmitteln dazuhaben.
Denn ich kann zum Beispiel immer kochen und backen
einfach aus dem Stegreif.
Ich muss nicht extra einkaufen gehen.
Und einen gesunden Lebensmittelvorrat dazuhaben,
ist auch wirklich gut.
Vor allem ist es gut, wenn man ihn dahat
für die nächsten 14 Tage eben für die Personen,
die bei euch im Haushalt leben.
Ich kann auch immer spontan Gäste empfangen.
Ich kann immer spontan einen Kuchen backen.
Und ich muss vor allem nicht so oft einkaufen gehen,
wenn ich so nämlich meinen Einkauf plane,
meinen Vorrat plane, sodass ich immer alles dahabe.
Und ich denke, jeder hat Platz genug, um zu sagen,
ich habe einen kleinen Vorrat für mich,
sei es im Kühlschrank oder in einem Vorratsschrank
oder eben auch in der Gefrierkühltruhe.
Heute zeige ich euch,
wie ihr Lebensmittel haltbar machen könnt, vor allem,
wie ihr Lebensmittel, die ihr eingekauft habt, richtig lagert,
damit sie eben auch nicht so schnell schlecht werden,
und wie ihr sie eben für eine gewisse Zeit
haltbar machen könnt.
Da gibt es verschiedene Techniken.
Die sind auch schon teilweise Jahrhunderte alt.
Und die werden wir heute alle einzeln durchgehen.
Schlaue Leute sagen ja,
dass man ohne Essen
bis zu drei bis vier Wochen aushalten kann,
ohne Trinken aber nur drei bis vier Tage.
Deswegen sollte man auch einen Wasservorrat dahaben.
Wir hier zu Hause in Waghäusel, wir trinken Leitungswasser.
Wir haben nämlich auch eine Enthärtungsanlage,
also eine BWT-Anlage.
Die löst einfach den Kalk vom Hahnenwasser.
Und da können wir unser Leitungswasser
nämlich schön kalkfrei auch trinken.
Aber wir haben auch immer Sprudelwasser da,
also Wasser mit Kohlensäure.
Und ihr solltet immer einen Vorrat an Wasser
auch für die nächsten zwei Wochen dahaben.
Da rechnet man einfach pro Person zwei Liter am Tag.
Also wären das 14 Liter in der Woche pro Person,
die ihr dann eben rechnen müsst.
Wenn ihr ein Haushalt seid mit Tieren,
solltet ihr auch an den Tiervorrat denken.
Denn auch die Tiere sollen nicht hungern.
Und vor allem könnt ihr euch da viele Kosten sparen,
weil oft große Portionen im Angebot sind.
Und ihr habt eben immer was da
und müsst nicht so oft einkaufen gehen.
So viel dazu.
Und jetzt kommt wir zum Lebensmittelvorrat.
Wenn man sich frühere Zeiten anschaut,
da haben es die Menschen geschafft,
Lebensmittel länger haltbar zu machen,
obwohl sie keinen Strom hatten, keinen Kühlschrank
und keinen Gefrierschrank.
Da gab es zum einen die Methode des Säuerns,
das heißt Gemüse mit Essig einzulegen.
Meine Mama macht das auch regelmäßig,
ich denke, immer so im Spätsommer.
Da legt sie Rotkohl ein,
Bohnen,
Gurken,
Tomaten.
Alles kommt in so große Fässer.
Es kommt Essigwasser dazu.
Und dann dauert es ein paar Wochen,
bis das Gemüse eingelegt ist,
und dann hat sie es wirklich schön haltbar gemacht.
Ich persönlich habe mich da noch nicht daran gewagt.
Vielleicht mache ich das dieses Jahr mal.
Aber auch ich habe natürlich im Vorrat
Gemüse, was wirklich sauer eingelegt wurde,
wie zum Beispiel Sauerkraut,
Gurken oder auch Peperoni.
Und die habe ich dann da.
Und die sind auch, wenn sie angebrochen sind,
einfach etwas länger haltbar.
Und damit kann man dann leckere Salate machen,
in Gerichte mit einkochen
oder auch pur wie Antipasti zum Beispiel verzehren.
Eine weitere alte Technik
ist das Räuchern von Fleisch und Fisch.
Viele besitzen auch einen Räucherofen.
Früher hat man das wirklich auch ganz oft zu Hause gemacht.
Mittlerweile bekommt man die Produkte
natürlich auch in jedem Supermarkt.
Und auch da ist es so, dass diese Lebensmittel
einfach etwas länger haltbar sind
als zum Beispiel frisches Fleisch oder frischer Fisch.
Das Einlegen ist auch eine altbewährte Methode,
um Lebensmittel länger haltbar zu machen.
Das Einlegen bewirkt nämlich,
dass kein Sauerstoff an Lebensmittel kommt
und die eben dann nicht oxidieren
und dann nicht schlecht werden.
Einlegen kann man zum einen in Öl zum Beispiel.
So mache ich es gerne mit getrockneten Tomaten.
Die gibt es ja auch schon in Öl zu kaufen.
Selbstgemachtes Pesto.
Oder ihr könnt zum Beispiel einlegen in Salzlake.
Das mache ich auch nicht selber,
sondern kaufe zum Beispiel den Käse
eingelegt in Salzlake.
Zum Einlegen gehört zum Beispiel auch,
dass man Käse in Öl einlegen kann
und eben auch mit frischen Kräutern
oder Knoblauch verfeinern kann.
Dafür schneide ich Hirten- oder Schafskäse in feine Würfel,
[Musik]
lege gehackte Kräuter, Knoblauch und Pfeffer dazu
und fülle das Gefäß so weit mit Öl auf,
bis alle Lebensmittel bedeckt sind
und somit kein Sauerstoff mehr daran kommt.
[Musik]
Einlegen kann man aber auch in Alkohol.
Viele kennen vielleicht den Rumtopf von der Oma noch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es heutzutage noch praktiziert wird,
ob ihr das auch kennt von eurer Oma.
Ich kenne es nicht,
weil ich nie eine Oma hatte, die einen Rumtopf hatte.
Aber einlegen kann man zum Beispiel Früchte in Rum.
Da gibt es dann den Rumtopf
und dann wird im Mai begonnen,
habe ich jetzt nachgelesen.
Da kommt dann die erste Frucht rein.
Das sind Erdbeeren.
Die zweite Schicht sind dann zum Beispiel Aprikosen
oder Pfirsiche.
Und so könnt ihr dann von Mai bis September
oder Oktober sogar
Früchte einlegen in einen großen Rumtopf.
Da kommt dann noch Zucker mit dazu.
Und dann zieht das Ganze durch.
Und man hat so eben bewirkt, dass man praktisch
Sommerfrüchte auch im Winter verzehren kann.
Also Anfang Dezember ist dann alles durchgezogen.
Und dann serviert man das als Kompott zu Eis
oder zu Waffeln oder auch zu einem Käsekuchen
und hat eben im Winter auch frische Früchte,
aber eben eingelegt aus dem Sommer.
Und so kann man eben die Lebensmittel auch haltbar machen.
Und vor allem gerade hier bei dem eingelegten Gemüse
oder auch beim Pesto mit Öl
ist es so, dass ich hier zum einen die Tomaten verwende,
die ich eingelegt habe,
aber eben auch das Öl,
weil da jetzt auch der volle Geschmack
der Tomaten zum Beispiel mit drin steckt.
Salz
ist hygroskopisch,
entzieht Lebensmitteln also die Feuchtigkeit
und nimmt so Mikroorganismen die Grundlage,
sich zu vermehren.
Das heißt, Lebensmittel werden auch dadurch
nicht schlecht.
Lebensmittel kann man mit Salz auch haltbar machen.
Hat man auch früher schon gemacht,
vor allem mit Fleisch und Fisch.
Aber auch in der afrikanischen und marokkanischen Küche
gibt es zum Beispiel Salzzitronen,
die eben...
Also, wo einfach Zitronen in Salz eingelegt werden,
und die man dann zum Verfeinern und zum Würzen
von Gerichten verwendet.
Ich habe jetzt selber noch nichts mit Salz eingelegt.
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch jemanden von euch,
der sagt: "Hey, ich habe schon Salzzitronen gemacht!"
Dann schreibt doch gerne mal in die Kommentare,
was ihr damit macht,
also wie man es weiterverwendet.
Und vielleicht könne wir das ja auch mal
in unser Rezeptsortiment mit aufnehmen.
Wenn ihr euch einen Lebensmittelvorrat zulegt,
ist es natürlich auch wichtig,
dass ihr die Lebensmittel richtig lagert,
damit sie so lange wie möglich halten
und eben nicht verderben.
Da gehört der Kühlschrank auf jeden Fall mit dazu.
Wenn ihr nach dem Einkaufen nach Hause kommt,
wirklich immer alles schön
sofort in den Kühlschrank einräumen
und da aber auch richtig einräumen!
Denn jeder Kühlschrank hat Zonen.
Unten ist es kälter als oben.
Und so hat jedes Lebensmittel
seinen perfekten Platz im Kühlschrank,
damit es eben auch die perfekte Temperatur abbekommt.
Das zeige ich euch in diesem Video nicht.
Dazu gibt es nämlich schon ein ausführliches Video,
wo ihr euch anschauen könnt,
wie man den Kühlschrank richtig einräumt.
Eine Methode, Lebensmittel haltbar zu machen,
ist das Dörren beziehungsweise Trocknen.
Entweder macht ihr das mit dem Backofen
oder mithilfe eines Dörrautomaten.
Und ich mache das jetzt so,
ich habe jetzt hier Obst und Gemüse,
jetzt erst mal Obst.
Denn Obstchips essen wir ganz gerne als Snack.
Das ist immer praktisch, wenn man unterwegs ist.
Dann habe ich es in der Handtasche.
Die Kinder nehmen es gerne mit.
Oder einfach so, wenn wir abends auf dem Sofa sitzen.
Und vor allem kann ich so Obst und Gemüse auch retten,
was sonst vielleicht verschimmeln würde,
weil es einfach schon ewig lange rumsteht.
Und, wenn wir jetzt gerade nicht Lust auf Smoothies haben
oder auf Fruchteis,
dann wird es eben kurz gedörrt,
wird so länger haltbar gemacht.
Es kann nicht mehr kaputtgehen
und wir haben einfach immer was auf Vorrat.
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach schon mal
ein paar Äpfel und Birnen,
eine Ananas.
Hier habe ich auch schon eine Mango
geschält.
Gleich hole ich noch Gemüse mit dazu.
Und im Prinzip ist beim Dörren einfach nur wichtig,
das Obst und Gemüse ganz dünn zu schneiden
oder dünn zu hobeln,
damit es eben auch gleichmäßig und schnell trocknet.
Also ich zeige euch das jetzt mal hier
mit den Äpfeln.
Die habe ich jetzt gewaschen schon.
Die entkerne ich kurz.
Die Schale lasse ich dran.
Unter der Schale sitzen ja sowieso meist
die wertvollen Nährstoffe.
Und entweder könnt ihr sie jetzt hier hobeln,
also mit so einem ganz normalem Hobel,
oder ihr könnt auch einen  Sparschäler verwenden.
Wäre jetzt beim Apfel ein bisschen schwierig.
Bei der Mango geht es etwas einfacher.
Ich zeige euch das jetzt mal hier schön dünn.
Und dann habt ihr diese Apfelringe.
Und hier muss ich jetzt den Fingerschutz nehmen.
Aber, wenn der Apfel zu groß ist,
genau, dann geht es gar nicht.
Bei größeren Leben-
Also hier kann ich jetzt den Apfel auch halbieren
und dann einfach
weiterhobeln.
Und bei größeren Lebensmitteln
da eignet sich ganz gut ein Allesschneider
oder einfach ein größerer Hobel.
Dann habt ihr da keine Probleme damit.
Dann habe ich jetzt hier keine Apfelringe,
sondern Apfelmonde.
Wenn ihr aber sowieso viel machen möchtet
und einen Allesschneider habt,
könnt ihr das auch wirklich schön
mit dem Allesschneider machen.
Da kann ich nämlich ganz viel,
eine ganz große Menge auch zubereiten
und eben auch ziemlich schnell und gleichmäßig.
Ich werde jetzt hier auch gleich die Äpfel in Wasser legen
mit etwas Zitronensaft,
damit sie beim Dörren nicht braun werden.
Also hier einfach eine große Schale mit Wasser,
ein bisschen Zitrone rein
und die Äpfel dazu.
Und in der Zeit kann ich die übrigen Äpfel auch schon
fein schneiden.
Und beim Apfel könnt ihr das Kerngehäuse entfernen
oder auch einfach dran lassen.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier noch meine Birnenscheiben.
Apfelscheiben.
Ich lege die jetzt auch schon mal auf meinen Dörrautomaten.
Denn ich muss gucken, wie viel Platz ich dann noch habe
und ob die Ananas heute noch darauf passt oder eher morgen.
Ich habe jetzt hier die Äpfel noch mal
ein bisschen abtrocknen lassen und abtropfen lassen,
damit die Feuchtigkeit schon mal nicht entzogen werden muss.
Ich packe sie jetzt hier direkt auf die Bleche.
Ich mache das jetzt im Dörrautomaten.
Den kann ich nämlich einfach den ganzen Tag laufen lassen
und blockiere meine Backöfen nicht.
Im Backofen könnt ihr auch dörren,
aber ihr habt dort nicht so viele Einschubhöhen
wie in einem Dörrautomaten
und vor allem müsst ihr dann wirklich
den Backofen acht bis zehn Stunden laufen lassen bei Umluft,
damit überhaupt das Obst und Gemüse gedörrt werden kann.
Also, wenn ihr öfter dörrt,
dann finde ich einen Dörrautomaten wirklich ideal,
weil man das wirklich jeden Tag nebenher machen kann.
Und dann hat man ihn auch wirklich
immer wieder im Gebrauch.
Ich lege das jetzt hier auf die einzelnen Fächer drauf,
kann auch dann ganz präzise
bei ganz wenig Temperatur dörren.
So bleiben die Vitamine auch schön erhalten.
Und alles, was jetzt noch so megaklein ist,
nehme ich jetzt zur Seite.
Daraus mache ich nämlich gleich Smoothie-Päckchen.
Also die schmeiße ich nicht weg!
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Ich habe noch Platz für Mango!
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt meine Mango.
Bei der Mango funktioniert es am besten,
wenn man sie schält und dann am V-Hobel direkt fein hobelt.
[Musik]
Und hier beim Drauflegen einfach nur darauf achten,
dass sich das Obst nicht berührt,
damit es eben nicht zusammenklebt.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier alles sechs Bleche drin.
Hier habe ich noch Ananas übrig
und hole noch anderes Obst.
Denn ich habe einen zweiten Dörrautomaten.
Wie gesagt, könnt ihr es im Dörrautomaten
dörren und trocknen
oder im Backofen.
Im Backofen dann auch bei maximal 50°C.
Hier kann ich die Temperatur
auch noch ganz präzise einstellen.
Manche Dinge, die trockne ich auch nur bei 40°C
oder bei 35°C.
Und im Backofen je nachdem, was für ein Modell ihr habt,
ist es halt auch nicht so energieeffizient.
Also da müsst ihr einfach mal schauen.
Ich stelle das gleich jetzt auch rüber in meine Abstellkammer.
Aber er ist auch nicht laut.
Also ich könnte ihn auch in der Küche stehen lassen.
Nur, dass ich hier gleich wieder Platz habe.
Das, was gerade gebrummt hat,
war übrigens der Backofen.
Der hat nämlich gerade abgepumpt, weil ich da
was gedämpft habe.
Okay. Hier mache ich jetzt mal acht Stunden.
Nee, neun Stunden.
Ich habe sie ein bisschen dicker gelassen.
50°C.
Fertig.
Okay. Ich mache jetzt hier noch ein bisschen Obst.
Morgen mache ich erst Gemüse.
Dann habe ich es einfach
schön separat auch.
Und dann zeige ich euch noch weitere
Dinge, die ihr trocknen könnt.
[Musik]
Ich liebe ja meine Kräuter hier draußen im Hochbeet!
Und gerade im Sommer komme ich dann echt
immer gerne raus, pflücke sie ganz frisch.
Im Winter ist das Kräuterhochbeet
natürlich ein bisschen zugefroren
und es gibt wenige, die einfach überwintern.
Das heißt, ich kann mir die jetzt hier im Sommer
schön abpflücken,
– jetzt wächst auch alles gut nach –
kann es dann dörren
und dadurch intensiviert sich natürlich auch das Aroma.
Das heißt, ich habe dann einfach
keinen Feuchtigkeitsgehalt mehr in den Kräutern
und habe schön die getrockneten Kräuter
mit dem vollen, intensiven Aroma.
Ich habe jetzt hier ein bisschen Bergbohnenkraut,
Fenchel und Minze.
Hier nehme ich noch ein bisschen Maggikraut.
Wächst sowieso ganz stark hier.
Und dann habe ich meinen Vorrat.
Gut.
Die Kräuter müssen jetzt im Prinzip nur gewaschen werden.
Und dann können sie auch schon trocknen.
Entweder macht ihr es so wie meine Mama.
Sie breitet immer ein großes Tuch aus,
am besten immer auf dem Esstisch.
Aber dann liegt das dort eben auch so etwa eine Woche lang,
bis die Kräuter ganz trocken sind.
Oder ihr trocknet sie im Dörrautomaten.
So mache ich es.
Ich schleudere jetzt noch die Kräuter etwas trocken.
So habe ich nämlich noch die Restfeuchtigkeit direkt weg.
Und dann kann ich hier auf mehreren Ebenen
einfach die Kräuter dörren.
Oder, wie gesagt, auf einem Geschirrtuch
oder zum Beispiel auf einem großen Küchentuch,
also auf so einer Tischdecke,
einfach mehrere Tage trocknen.
Hach, das riecht jetzt schon gut!
Das riecht super!
Und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
die lege ich auch so ein bisschen übereinander
so auf eine komplette Ebene.
Das trocknet dann trotzdem gut durch.
[Musik]
Ja, so sieht das dann bei mir typischerweise aus,
wenn ich viel dörre.
Und ich mache es wirklich fast wöchentlich.
Also es gibt auch mal eine Woche,
wo ich gar nicht gedörrt habe.
Aber dann habe ich wieder so einen Dörrschwung
und dörre, was das Zeug hält.
Gerade jetzt im Sommer wächst ja auch vieles
bei uns im Garten.
Ich habe...
Das sind jetzt meine Vorräte vom letzten Jahr sogar noch,
meine Kräutervorräte.
Da habe ich zum Beispiel meinen Salbei gedörrt.
Hier vorne habe ich Sellerie.
Da habe ich einen Knollensellerie bei mir im Hochbeet,
habe dann das Grün gedörrt
und habe aber auch die Sellerieknolle gedörrt.
Das heißt, ich habe hier
den Sellerie in Würfel geschnitten
und dann einfach gedörrt.
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach immer schön
für Suppen oder für Gerichte meine Gewürze.
Fenchel habe ich hier,
wenn Ela nicht den kompletten Fenchel vom Hochbeet aufisst.
Und hier habe ich einfach verschiedene Sorten
wie zum Beispiel Zitronenverbene.
Das heißt, ich habe hier auch meine Grundlagen zum Kochen,
aber auch zum Genießen.
Denn daraus mache ich auch gerne Tee.
Gerade Zitronenverbenetee ist megalecker!
Und durch das Dörren mache die Lebensmittel
nicht nur haltbarer, sondern
man intensiviert auch den Geschmack,
weil einfach das Wasser entzogen wird.
Und ich habe dann den vollen Geschmack
mit sogar ganz wenig Volumen nur.
Ja.
Schön komprimiert.
Bei diesem wilden Haufen hier handelt es sich um das Thema
Einfrieren.
Denn auch das Einfrieren ist eine gute Methode,
um Lebensmittel auf Vorrat immer dazuhaben.
Es setzt natürlich voraus, dass man einen Gefrierschrank hat.
Wir hatten früher auch nur so ein kleines Gefrierfach
und da musste ich halt immer gucken,
was überhaupt reinpasst,
war immer nur eine begrenzte Menge.
Jetzt haben wir einen Gefrierschrank mit Schiebern.
Ich muss trotzdem sagen, meine Mama hat immer noch
den größeren Gefrierschrank.
Und ich halt nicht. Deswegen...
Ich habe aber auch ganz gerne den Vorrat dort
immer im Überblick und einfach immer nicht zu viel.
Lebensmittel könnt ihr im Gefrierschrank
bis zu ein Jahr bevorraten.
Und da gibt es einfach viele Dinge,
die man auf Vorrat haben kann,
und manche Dinge, die sollte man nicht einfrieren.
Also ich arbeite mich mal von hier nach da.
Was ihr immer ganz gut einfrieren könnt, ist Fleisch.
Da habe ich zum einen immer Hackfleisch da,
weil ich einfach Fleisch am Stück kaufe.
Das geht alles durch den Fleischwolf.
Ich vakuumiere es dann.
Das heißt, ich packe es hier in kleine Behälter,
in kleine Beutel,
drücke es schön flach
und vakuumiere es.
So bekommt es zum einen keinen Gefrierbrand,
ist fest verschlossen
und, wenn ich es dann auftauen möchte,
geht es auch superschnell,
weil das Hackfleisch wirklich schön flach ist
und nicht als große Kugel.
Es gibt auch viele, die Hackfleisch abgepackt kaufen
in diesen Kunststoffverpackungen.
Und da ist natürlich ganz viel Luft drin.
Und, wenn ihr das so einfach einfriert,
ist das Auftauen viel, viel mühsamer,
weil es eben viel länger dauert.
Also wirklich Hackfleisch schön flach einfrieren.
Dann habe ich auch immer ganz gerne
Hähnchen zum Beispiel vakuumiert und eingefroren.
Oder
beispielsweise auch Elas und Murats Lieblingswürstchen,
die werden auch einfach vakuumiert und eingefroren.
Und so entsteht dann eben auch
im Gefrierfach kein Gefrierbrand.
Was ihr auch immer wunderbar einfrieren könnt, sind Kräuter.
Ich habe zum Beispiel gerne Schnittlauch
und auch Petersilie auf Vorrat.
Ich schneide es dann vorher klein,
habe es hier in den Dosen drin
und, wenn ich es dann brauche,
kann man es schön rausnehmen.
Ihr seht, es klebt dann auch nicht zusammen.
Es gibt Kräuter, die lassen sich nicht so gut einfrieren,
Basilikum zum Beispiel,
das verliert einfach total an Geschmack.
Aber jetzt gerade die zwei Kräuter,
also Schnittlauch und Petersilie,
habe ich eigentlich immer im Vorrat.
Wenn wir schon beim Würzen sind,
ihr könnt auch immer gut
Zitronen- und Orangenschale einfrieren.
Ich kaufe ja meist Bio-Zitronen,
bei denen man die Schale auch verzehren kann.
Und manchmal brauche ich aber keine Zitronenschale.
Und dann reibe ich die vorher einfach ab,
kann sie hier in ein Gefäß geben und einfrieren
und habe dann eben auch immer Zitronenschale auf Vorrat da.
Was man auch wunderbar einfrieren kann, ist Gebäck.
Also zum einen Brot,
natürlich immer schön verpackt.
Da haben wir gerne Fladenbrot da.
Und zum anderen könnt ihr auch anderes Gebäck einfrieren
wie Berliner oder Kuchen
und müsst sie dann einfach nur noch
bei Raumtemperatur auftauen lassen
oder eben ganz kurz in der Mikrowelle.
So was könnt ihr immer gut einfrieren,
vor allem, wenn ihr mal zu viel von was dahabt,
und habt es dann eben auch im Gefrierfach einfach da.
Hier habe ich noch Tomatenmark.
Das kaufe ich immer gerne in so einer großen Verpackung,
wobei das für türkische Verhältnisse eine kleine
Drei-Tages-Verpackung ist.
Also eine große türkische Verpackung ist dann so,
so fünf Liter Tomatenmark.
Und ich persönlich, ich liebe Tomatenmark,
aber ich benutze es jetzt nicht jeden Tag.
Das heißt, ich habe schon die Erfahrung gemacht,
wenn ich so ein Glas habe
und
ich benutze es eine Weile nicht,
fängt es natürlich an zu schimmeln im Kühlschrank.
Jetzt könnt ihr Folgendes tun.
Entweder glättet ihr jetzt hier die Oberfläche,
schüttet Öl darüber,
also wieder einlegen,
sodass einfach kein Sauerstoff an die Oberfläche kommt.
Könnt ihr machen.
Dann ist es wirklich mehrere Wochen haltbar im Kühlschrank.
Nur muss man immer sauber vorgehen,
weil gerade hier diese Ränder,
die man da hat, die dann nicht mit Öl bedeckt sind,
können dann anfangen zu schimmeln.
Oder ihr macht es einfach so wie ich.
Ihr nehmt Eiswürfelbehälter mit Deckel,
streicht hier das Tomatenmark rein,
zieht es schön glatt mit einem Teigschaber
und dann wird es abgedeckt
und eingefroren.
Und dann könnt ihr einfach,
wenn ihr ein bisschen Tomatenmark braucht,
das hier schön rausdrücken
und habt gleich eine schöne, kleine Portion.
Und so habe ich das jetzt auch gemacht,
habe hier Tomatenmark und Paprikamark,
habe es schön im Vorrat und direkt schon vorportioniert.
Und, wenn ihr keine Eiswürfelformen mit Deckel habt,
nehmt ihr einfach eine Gefriertüte für das Tomatenmark.
Da wird es dann eingefüllt.
Dann ganz wichtig, umschlagen hier oben
oder vakuumieren.
Könnt ihr auch machen.
Es gibt ja auch diese Zipp-Behälter,
diese Zipp-Tüten.
Dann könnt ihr die auch oben zumachen.
Jetzt wieder schön glatt machen.
Mit einer Teigkarte
kann man das hier dann so einteilen.
Und dann habt ihr auch Einzelportionen,
die ihr dann nach dem Einfrieren einfach auftauen könnt.
Gemüse lässt sich natürlich auch super einfrieren.
Da habe ich zum einen selbst eingefrorenes Gemüse,
wie jetzt Bohnen
oder hier Mangold von meinem Hochbeet.
Oder ich habe auch immer Gemüse da,
wie zum Beispiel gefrorene Erbsen.
Die kaufe ich dann.
Ich habe dann auch ein Fach für Gemüse
und dann ist es da einfach alles immer drinnen.
Was habe ich noch?
Hier habe ich noch Früchte.
Das hier sind jetzt gekaufte Früchte.
Aber ihr könnt natürlich auch,
wenn gerade Früchtesaison ist
und ihr habt viele Erdbeeren, Heidelbeeren, Himbeeren da,
einfach verpacken,
entweder auch vakuumieren
oder in ein luftdichtes Gefäß packen
und einfrieren.
Und, was viele nicht wissen,
ihr könnt Bananen einfrieren.
Und diese Bananen waren,
bevor ich sie eingefroren habe, gelb.
Sie waren zwar schon schön reif,
also so leicht brauchen Flecken.
Die habe ich dann einfach so eingefroren.
Und so habe ich immer schöne, kalte Bananen da.
Die Schale wird zwar hässlich braun,
aber im Inneren ist sie jetzt noch schön gelb,
also nicht braun.
Und die kann ich jetzt benutzen und schälen,
um zum Beispiel Smoothies zu machen
oder um ein Eis herzustellen.
Und dann habe ich einfach schon
direkt die kalte Obstsorte mit dabei,
brauche keine Eiswürfel und habe sozusagen dann
keine Verwässerung des Geschmacks.
Also ich habe einfach die kalte Banane
und die sorgt dann eben dafür,
dass das Getränk oder das Eis schön kalt ist.
Ihr könnt sie auch gerne vorher in Scheiben schneiden
und schälen und dann einfrieren.
Das geht auch.
Und genauso könnt ihr auch Ingwer
oder Kurkuma immer bevorraten im Gefrierfach.
Ihr könnt Chilis ganz gut einfrieren.
Die kann man dann auch superklein reiben,
wenn sie gefroren sind.
Ihr könnt Hefe immer super einfrieren.
Also ich friere die entweder als Hefewürfel ein
oder als selbst gezüchtete Hefe,
– da gibt es auch schon ein Video –
wo ich sie dann auch portionsweise rausdrücken kann.
Käse könnt ihr auch super einfrieren.
Gerade, wenn ihr hier so einen großen Käse habt,
so einen Hirtenkäse,
der hat 800 Gramm Abtropfgewicht.
Das heißt, da sind, glaube ich, vier
oder viereinhalb Rädchen Käse drin.
Und das isst man jetzt auch nicht immer auf einmal auf.
Und, wenn ich da mal was übrig habe,
nehme ich den einfach raus, das komplette Rädchen,
verpacke es luftdicht
und dann wird es eingefroren.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass Hirtenkäse
oder generell Milchprodukte,
wenn sie eingefroren werden,
krisselig schmecken können.
Das heißt, ich benutze den Käse dann wirklich
nur noch zum Überbacken oder zum Gratinieren
oder für in den Toast zum Beispiel rein.
Auch mit Schnittkäse funktioniert das prima.
Aber Parmesan oder Grana Padano
könnt ihr zum Beispiel super einfrieren
und dann einfach hobeln
und über die Pastagerichte trotzdem noch verwenden.
Was ich nicht einfriere,
ist zum Beispiel saure Sahne oder Schmand.
Die habe ich einfach im Kühlschrank immer.
Sahne kann man anscheinend auch wunderbar einfrieren.
Probiert habe ich es noch nicht.
Wie gesagt, Milchprodukte können krisselig werden.
Aber, was ihr auch gut einfrieren könnt, ist Butter.
Das heißt, wenn ihr mal Butter im Angebot habt
oder wenn ihr zu viel Butter habt,
einfach nur einfrieren
und vor dem Benutzen wieder auftauen lassen.
Funktioniert super für Hefegebäck, für Rührteige,
für Buttercremes.
Da habt ihr wirklich dann immer was da.
Wenn wir beim Thema Backen sind:
Wenn ich Motivtorten mache, habe ich auch immer
ganz gerne mal Ganache übrig.
Und Ganache kann man auch einfrieren.
Also die habe ich jetzt hier noch übrig gehabt.
Ich habe weiße und dunkle und Vollmilch-Ganache übrig,
friere sie einfach ein
und, bevor ich sie benutze, wird sie einfach aufgetaut.
Ich kann sie noch mal kurz erwärmen,
damit sie eben wieder schön geschmeidig ist.
Und dann ganz normal weiter verwenden.
Genauso könnt ihr es mit Eiern machen.
Eier kann man auch gut einfrieren.
Danach halt muss man sie halt komplett durchgegart essen.
Man darf sie nicht mit der Schale einfrieren,
weil sie eben platzt.
Das sollte man vielleicht dazusagen.
Aber gerade, wenn ihr Eigelb übrig habt
oder Eiweiß übrig habt,
weil ihr zum Beispiel nur
die andere Komponente gebraucht habt,
könnt ihr es in ein Gefäß geben und einfrieren
und dann einfach beim Backen benutzen.
Und da kann man sich ganz gut merken,
vor allem, wenn man nicht mehr weiß,
wie viele Eigelbe oder wie viel Eiweiß in der Schale sind,
kann man sich einfach das Gewicht des Eies
ein bisschen ausrechnen.
Und zwar hat ein Ei der Größe M
immer etwa 15 Gramm Eigelb und 35 Gramm Eiweiß.
Und so passt es dann in der Regel generell immer so dazu.
Was man nicht so gut einfrieren kann, ist Blattsalat,
weil Blattsalat nach dem Gefrieren
natürlich einfach matschig wird und zerfällt.
Die einzige Ausnahme ist im Prinzip Spinat oder Mangold.
Denn Spinat oder Mangold wird meist
sowieso gekocht verzehrt.
Das heißt, Spinat könnt ihr entweder kurz vorkochen,
also blanchieren, und einfrieren
oder eben auch schon gefroren kaufen.
Aber jetzt Blattsalate, Chicorée, Eisbergsalat, Kopfsalat,
da funktioniert es halt nicht so gut.
Und, was man auch nicht einfrieren sollte,
sind wasserreiche Obst- und Gemüsesorten,
also so was wie Orangen, Gurken, Wassermelone,
das wird einfach alles sehr matschig.
Was ihr aber machen könnt, ist,
ihr könnt den Saft der Orangen zum Beispiel auspressen
und dann einfach in Eiswürfelformen geben,
einfrieren
und habt dann einfach schöne, kühle Eiswürfel,
um zum Beispiel ein Getränk herunterzukühlen.
Was man da auch ganz gut einfrieren kann,
sind Teige, wie zum Beispiel Hefeteiggebäck, wie Pizza
oder auch Baguette, Brötchen.
Die kann man sich vorbacken oder auch roh einfrieren
und dann einfach nach dem Einfrieren
in den Backofen schieben oder auch frittieren,
Donuts zum Beispiel.
Was ihr auch gut einfrieren könnt, ist zum Beispiel Blätterteig.
Den stelle ich auch ganz gerne selber her.
Oder ich kaufe auch mal einen Blätterteig
und habe den dann auch einfach im Vorrat.
Was wirklich niemals,
never ever in den Kühlschrank
und auch nicht in den Gefrierschrank darf,
sind Kartoffeln.
Die werden nämlich...
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist es euch mal passiert,
dass Kartoffeln zu kalt gelagert wurden.
Und die werden einfach ganz süß,
wenn sie eingefroren werden oder auch gekühlt werden,
und werden auch relativ matschig.
Also irgendwie verwandelt sich die Stärke in Zucker um.
Sie schmecken komplett süß
und eben gar nicht mehr so nach Kartoffeln.
Also das solltet ihr auf jeden Fall vermeiden!
Was ihr auch ganz gut
mit Obst- und Gemüseresten machen könnt, ist,
dass ihr Obst- und Gemüsereste direkt
in kleine Tüten abfüllt oder in kleine Behälter,
könnt sie einfrieren
und dann habt ihr immer direkt eine Smoothie-Portion,
die ihr einfach nur noch mixen müsst,
für jeden Tag.
Also da kann man auch so ein bisschen Food Prep machen,
so ein bisschen Essensvorbereitung.
Einfach die Ananas schneiden, Mango schneiden,
Obst und Gemüse dazu,
einfrieren in Tüten
und dann habt ihr jeden Tag eine schöne Portion Smoothies.
Eine weiter Methode, Dinge
oder Lebensmittel haltbarer zu machen, ist das Vakuumieren.
Denn beim Vakuumieren wird einfach der Sauerstoff,
also die Luft, entzogen
und die Lebensmittel sind länger haltbar.
Ganz gut ist es sogar,
wenn man das Vakuumieren und das Einfrieren kombiniert.
So könnt ihr zum Beispiel Fleisch,
was normalerweise ein Jahr ungefähr haltbar wäre,
im Gefrierschrank durch das Vakuumieren
auf das Doppelte haltbar machen.
Also die zwei kombiniert sind echt gut!
Denn durch das Vakuumieren
entsteht einfach kein Gefierfrost auf den Lebensmitteln.
Also ihr könnt zum Beispiel Fleisch vakuumieren
und es dann in den Kühlschrank legen,
damit es länger haltbar ist.
Ihr könnt so wie hier Maronen einkochen und vakuumieren.
Ihr könnt aber auch offenes Gebäck, offene Tüten,
wie Chips oder Salzbrezeln...
Ich weiß, bei vielen bleiben die nicht offen.
Es bleibt einfach nichts mehr übrig.
Denn, wenn sie einmal geöffnet sind, sind sie leer.
Aber, wenn ihr sie geöffnet habt
und ihr sagt, ihr wollt
sie in der originalen Verpackung aufbewahren,
könnt ihr die auch wieder vakuumieren
und die Luft entziehen.
Ihr könnt aber auch Cremes...
Ich habe hier zum Beispiel
so eine Frischkäse-Paprika-Creme gemacht,
die jetzt hier eingefüllt.
Das ist wie so eine Creme vom Türken oder vom Griechen.
Und die kann ich jetzt auch vakuumieren
und die Luft entziehen.
Oder ich kann auch Kaffee wieder vakuumieren.
Wir benutzen immer Kaffeebohnen.
Und bei Kaffeebohnen ist es zum Beispiel so,
da haben die Tüten hier wie so eine Art Ventil.
Denn bei Kaffeebohnen ist ganz wichtig beim Vakuumieren,
dass nicht zu viel Vakuum,
also nicht zu viel Vakuum gemacht wird,
dass nicht zu viel Luft rausgezogen wird
und somit das Aroma verschwindet.
Also sorgt hier das Ventil dann dafür,
dass doch noch so ein bisschen Zirkulation da ist.
Jetzt könnt ihr zum einen mit einem Vakuumiergerät arbeiten
so, wie ich es habe.
Unter der Kaffeemaschine habe ich
so eine elektrische Vakuumierpumpe.
Oder ihr nehmt so ein manuelles Gerät.
Da gibt es spezielle Tüten dafür.
Das heißt, ihr habt so einen Zipp-Behälter,
setzt es hier an und zieht die Luft raus.
Und so könnt ihr zum Beispiel auch Salami,
Obst und Gemüse vakuumieren
und das Ganze wirklich länger
im Kühlschrank auch haltbar machen.
Oder, wie gesagt, wenn ihr ein Vakuumiergerät habt,
könnt ihr auch so flache Gläser reinstellen.
Es gibt auch einen Schlauch.
Da könnt ihr auch große Behälter vakuumieren
oder, wie gesagt, eben solche Behälter,
solche Tüten wieder verschließen.
Hier habe ich meine Vakuumierschublade.
Und, wie gesagt, habe ich hier den Schlauch.
So kann ich wirklich auch große Behälter anschließen
und vakuumieren, ohne dass ich sie hier reinstellen muss.
Fleisch vakuumiere ich ganz gerne.
Zum einen, weil es länger haltbar ist,
aber zum anderen auch zur Aromabildung.
Ich kann jetzt hier nämlich auch Rosmarin dazu geben,
ein bisschen Butter dazu geben.
Also ich kann im Prinzip den Geschmack, den ich möchte,
hier mit reingeben in kleinster Menge.
Denn durch das Vakuumieren entsteht hier ein Unterdruck
und das Aroma zieht sofort ins Fleisch ein.
Genauso bei Obstsalat.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel Obstsalat zubereiten wollt,
alles in einen Behälter geben,
hier kurz vakuumieren
und dann blubbert das auch so richtig, als würde es kochen.
Aber es kocht nicht.
Aber das Aroma zieht sofort ein.
Also, wenn ihr da ein bisschen Vanille zum Beispiel daran gebt,
ist es sofort eingezogen.
Und ihr müsst Dinge und Lebensmittel
einfach nicht lange marinieren lassen,
sondern es geht in Sekundenschnelle.
Wie gesagt, kann ich jetzt hier noch die Creme vakuumieren.
Die ist dann auch länger haltbar,
ist dann nicht mehr anfällig.
Guckt!
Jetzt ist es ganz fest zu.
[Musik]
Das Einkochen ist auch eine altbewährte Methode,
um Lebensmittel länger haltbar zu machen
und um sie zu konservieren.
So könnt ihr zum Beispiel Früchte
zu Marmelade, Gelee oder Kompott verarbeiten.
Ihr könnt Soßen herstellen,
Suppen einkochen
oder auch ganze Gerichte wie Chili con Carne
oder eine Bolognese einkochen.
Ich habe hier verschiedene Soßen.
Und so könnt ihr euch Lebensmittel wirklich schön einkochen.
Ich zeige euch jetzt nicht genau wie.
Denn da gibt es ja schon einige Rezepte auf meinem Kanal.
Wichtig ist im Prinzip nur,
dass ihr Gläser verwendet, die dann sterilisiert werden,
also gesäubert werden.
Die könnt ihr entweder in Wasser auskochen,
im Backofen sterilisieren,
in der Mikrowelle oder im Dampfgarer,
damit einfach keine Keime ins Innere gelangen
und sich vermehren können.
Und dann könnt ihr die Soßen kochen,
die Suppen, die Marmelade,
heiß einfüllen, verschließen
und dadurch gelangen dann eben
auch keine Keime ins Innere.
Ihr könnt dann eben schön das Gargut einfüllen,
verschließen.
Und so habt ihr es eben schön konserviert.
Und es ist mehrere Monate haltbar!
Zucker lieben ja fast alle.
Und Zucker ist auch wie Salz ein Konservierungsmittel
und wird eben auch
zum Konservieren von Lebensmitteln eingesetzt.
Das Ganze nennt sich dann kandieren.
Und ihr kennt vielleicht kandierten Ingwer.
Ihr kennt aber auch vielleicht Orangeat und Zitronat.
Da wird nämlich einfach durch Zucker,
durch eine Zuckerlösung,
die dann über die Früchte gegossen wird,
wird der Wassergehalt rausgezogen.
Das sind einfach osmotische Prozesse.
Und dadurch werden die Lebensmittel
eben auch länger haltbar.
Der Zuckergehalt steigt dann in den Früchten auf 70% an
mindestens.
Und ja, sie halten eben dann eigentlich fast ewig.
Ingwer, muss ich sagen, mag ich kandiert ganz gerne,
weil Ingwer so eine Schärfe hat
und dann durch die Süße einfach richtig gut schmeckt.
Ich selbst kandiere nicht, weil
ich denke mir halt,
bevor ich jetzt die Orangen und Zitronen kandiere,
kann ich sie auch direkt dörren,
habe da einfach keinen Zucker mit dabei.
Und vor allem könnt ihr kandierte Früchte...
Kann man wahrscheinlich auch gut mal was
für was Herzhaftes verarbeiten
oder zu was Herzhaftem verarbeiten,
aber im Prinzip bringt es einfach noch mehr Zucker rein.
Und ich glaube, Zucker hat sowieso jeder
so ein bisschen im Überfluss.
Also ich denke, früher war das eine ganz gute Methode,
um Früchte eben länger haltbar zu machen.
Heute, würde ich jetzt eher sagen,
braucht man es vielleicht nicht unbedingt.
Für Lebkuchen ist es vielleicht ganz wichtig,
dass man Orangeat und Zitronat nimmt.
Aber ansonsten muss ich persönlich für mich sagen,
so Hefegebäck mag ich nicht mit Orangeat und Zitronat.
Aber kandierten Ingwer, den
nasche ich schon mal ganz gerne.
Ja.
Oder kandierte Rosenblätter oder Blütenblätter,
die kann man auch ganz gut machen.
Die kann man wirklich super haltbar machen.
Habe ich auch schon mal ausprobiert.
Und da, finde ich, macht es dann wieder Sinn,
weil man sie für die Deko benutzen kann
und die eben wirklich gar nicht halten würden.
Das waren jetzt meine zehn Tipps zur Konservierung
und zur Haltbarmachung von Lebensmitteln.
Natürlich solltet ihr immer einen gesunden Vorrat
zu Hause haben,
damit ihr eben spontan kochen und backen könnt,
nicht einkaufen gehen müsst
und eben nicht in so einen Notstand kommt,
dass ihr eben nichts zu Hause habt.
Außerdem ist es auch ganz gut für eure Kasse.
Denn ihr könnt gezielter einkaufen,
kauft nicht zu viel, aber auch nicht zu wenig.
Was ihr jetzt in eurem Vorratsschrank
oder in eurem Vorratsraum haben solltet,
kann ich euch ganz genau nicht sagen.
Denn das ist ja auch personenbezogen.
Manche essen lieber Nudeln,
– haben wir ja gemerkt –
andere lieber Kartoffeln
oder Reis.
Manche verzichten ganz auf Kohlenhydrate
und ernähren sich lieber ausschließlich von Gemüse und Obst.
Was ihr aber immer wissen solltet, ist,
egal, wie groß der Vorratsschrank ist oder der Vorratsraum,
haltet immer einen Überblick über eure Vorräte!
Wir haben hier unseren Vorratsschrank.
Drüben haben wir unseren Vorratsraum.
Aber der Vorratsschrank hier ist sozusagen unser
Back- und Kochvorratsschrank hier für die Videos
oder auch, wenn wir mit dem Team hier zusammenkommen.
Und ich habe hier oben zum Beispiel
so ein bisschen trockene Produkte, wie Zucker und Mehl,
Stärke, Salz,
verschiedene Mehlsorten.
Und wichtig ist, dass ihr beim Einkaufen darauf achtet:
Die alten Lebensmittel rutschen nach vorne
und die neu eingekauften kommen nach hinten.
So kann zum einen nichts verderben
und ihr behaltet einfach den Überblick.
Dann ist auch noch wichtig im Vorratsschrank:
Macht keine Experimente!
Das heißt, kauft nur Dinge auf Vorrat,
die ihr wirklich verzehrt.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel absolut keine Haferflocken esst,
müsst ihr auch keine Haferflocken auf Vorrat dahaben.
Die könnt ihr mal so ausprobieren,
so ein Päckchen ausprobieren.
Aber, wie gesagt, auf Vorrat hat man wirklich nur,
was man ständig und in großen Mengen
eben auch konsumiert.
Also hier oben habe ich
hier auf Sichthöhe sozusagen diese Vorräte.
Da habe ich jetzt auch keinen Schieber,
weil ich eben alles in einer Reihe hintereinander habe.
Und hier unten habe ich dann noch Schieber.
Da habe ich dann alles ganz übersichtlich drin,
wie zum Beispiel Milch.
Oder hier habe ich mein Kokosfett mit dabei.
Hier unten habe ich so die süße Schublade
mit Obstkonserven, Marmeladen oder Schokoladencreme.
Und hier links eher so das Herzhafte
wie Olivenöl, verschiedene andere Öle,
Dosen, Konserven,
Eingemachtes.
Und hier unten noch trockene Vorräte
wie Nudeln, Reis, Bulgur, Couscous oder Kaffee.
Also ich hoffe, euch hat dieses Video gefallen
und ihr habt die einen oder anderen Tipps und Tricks
mitgenommen zur Bevorratung und zum Haltbarmachen
von gewissen Lebensmitteln.
Sag mal. Kann das sein, dass ich lispel?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Schreibt mir gerne eure Tipps und Tricks
auch in die Kommentare.
Und wir sehen uns wieder das nächste Mal!
Und schreibt auch gerne,
wenn ihr weitere Videos dieser Art sehen möchtet,
den Vorratsschrank zum Beispiel
oder den Vorratsraum
oder noch weiter Tipps und Tricks rund um das Dörren.
Ja.
Schreibt mir einfach.
Tschüss!
Haben wir Möhren?
[Musik]